hop
[Musique]
dans le cadre du joli mois de l'europe
une journée d'information s'est déroulée
ce mardi 3 mai à la mfr maison familiale
rurale qui forment les jeunes au métier
d'agriculteur
c'est rejoindre une vice-présidence
département délégué à l'agriculture est
venu leur parler du feader le fonds
européen pour l'agriculture le
développement rural c'est essentiel de
faire passer le savoir et notamment
faire passer le savoir à nos jeunes qui
sont dans une orientation de soi de
devenir ouvrier agricole aux techniciens
écoles ou simplement devenir demain des
chefs d'exploitation
il a expliqué que dans le monde agricole
ils ne sont pas seuls ils peuvent être
soutenus par l'état le département la
région mais surtout par l'union
européenne l'union européenne qui
accorde une enveloppe exceptionnelle à à
la réunion 589 millions d'euros sur la
période
2014-2020 de et notre objectif c'est de
faire en sorte qu'aucun euro retourne à
l'europe donc il est important de
sensibiliser nos jeunes c'est un bon
temps où le fait d'un matin pour les
jeunes qui vont s'installer quand je
parle des jeunes parce que c'est notre
cas
connaître ça pourquoi pour palais peut
pas être laissée à l'abandon et
connaître vraiment
connaître vraiment les
les fonds les financements qu'on peut
avoir avec lui et puis voilà après
chacun jugera de s'il a besoin de ces
fonds là ou pas forcément pour
s'installer mais c'est bien de savoir
que s'effondra existe des vrais matin à
voir donc les jeunes pour pouvoir aider
les jeunes à leur installation
[Musique]